we have another great guest today
joining us today is secretary our new
secretary of housing and urban
development marcia fudge
who was confirmed just last week we
wasted no time as you all know secretary
fudge served as u.s representative for
the 11th congressional district of ohio
for more than
12 years she's a former chair of the
congressional black caucus and earned a
reputation of tackling
the unique challenges of our district by
working across political ideologies
in 1999 secretary fudge was the last
elected the first female
and first african-american mayor of
warrensville heights ohio a position she
held for two terms
as mayor of warrensville heights she
adopted one of the first vacant and
abandoned property ordinances in the
state
additionally she brought new residential
development to the city and addressed
the city's growing foreclosure crisis
through the formation of a long
partnership that helped residents
maintain the financial security needed
to buy
or keep a home as secretary fudge has
said
her first priority as secretary of
housing and urban development is to
alleviate the housing crisis
and get people the support they need to
come back from the edge she's happy to
take a couple of questions
after she gives some remarks thank you
again for joining
thank you very much jen good afternoon
good afternoon oh thank you thank you
i was wondering if i was in this room by
myself uh jen thanks for inviting me to
uh to speak about the importance of the
american rescue plan as it relates to
the urgent needs
housing needs facing our nation today
what a way to complete my very first
week as secretary of housing and urban
development
at hud we know firsthand the severe
impact of covet 19 on our nation's
housing crisis
hud staff in every region of the country
have worked
tirelessly to assist grantees and
recipients
of hud assistance in their response to
the pandemic
we've helped nurse hope we've helped
housing owners
housing authorities and communities
provide additional rental assistance
and support new efforts to eradicate
homelessness
we've extended the federal housing
administration's foreclosure and
eviction moratoriums
until june 30 to support the immediate
and ongoing needs of homeowners
under the biden-harris administration
hud is making greater efforts to keep
americans safe
from covet 19. we're strengthening
partnerships between recipients of hud
assistance
and public health agencies and
healthcare providers
many of the people living and living in
federally assisted housing
have risk factors that make them
particularly vulnerable to colvin
these factors include disability race
and low income
along with racial and ethnic disparities
in access to response care and
treatment we're making sure that federal
state and local efforts to reach those
most at risk of covet
are linking those efforts to people
living in housing hud supports
the american rescue plan is critical to
our success in these efforts
some of you may know that my last vote
as a member of congress was for
the american rescue plan i was proud to
vote for this historic legislation
to get help to the american people
during this moment of great challenge
i thank president biden for the
leadership that has gotten us to this
point
the american people can be confident
that help is here
the president has described the american
rescue plan as shots in arms
and money and pockets i would add it
relates to housing
the american rescue plan keeps people
housed and brings people home
and with that i would take any questions
that you would
that jen is going to allow me to take so
you'll make up any time
jen is in charge i'm just here go ahead
if i can't secretary fudge thank you for
being here we appreciate your time today
the head of the national housing
conference said that hud's ranks of
gutted morale has never been lowered the
challenges to hud's constituents
have never been higher just in simple
terms can you destroy
describe the state of your department as
you take it over today
well i would say this to you and i
actually had the opportunity to talk to
the president about it since i've been
here
we are thousands of people short of
where we ought to be
our staff is outstanding
they are under resourced understaffed
and overworked
but we are going to make some major
changes and very quickly the rescue plan
is allowing us
to do things that we may not have been
able to do without it so i am especially
pleased
that the president had the foresight and
the vision to give us a historic
maybe one-time opportunity to change
what is going on in housing in this
country
you put out some new numbers today as
they relate to homelessness in this
country right now obviously it's a
number that the
whole country is dissatisfied by i think
the number should be much lower
um i'll ask this in two different ways
one can you set a goal where you think
that number should be and in what time
frame you think you can meet such a goal
to
reduce homelessness in country in this
country and specifically
for some of the blue parts of the
country that some
republicans have criticized san
francisco new york where the homeless
numbers
have been high what specific advice and
what you can specif specifically do
to target those communities to alleviate
those
uh those high numbers well the first
thing i say is that the president gave
us a charge early on as to what he
wanted us to focus on
especially in the first 100 days
homelessness was at the top of the list
one was expanding vouchers thirdly he
wanted us to find ways to
expand and put in the market new
affordable housing so with the forty
billion dollars that has come that we
have now
what we expect is this we have five
billion dollars set aside to do nothing
but
address homeless issues so we know that
with those resources
over the next probably 12 to 18 months
we know for a fact that we can get as
many as 130 000 people off the streets
we also know that our local partners are
going to assist us in finding
other rental uh opportunities so we
believe we can put a major dent in it
but if nothing else what we will let
them know is that there is an
opportunity to find a way off the
streets we are
we we have more programs in place to
assist people who are already in public
housing
to find a way to buy housing we know
that affordable housing is a problem all
across this country
i don't know where my republican
colleagues live that don't think that it
that there is a problem but there is
so many of us just choose to ignore it
thank you for being here uh the
federal moratorium on evictions is set
to expire at the end of this month are
there plans to extend that
and if not what do you say to families
who are worried that they may be facing
well what i would say first is that the
hud moratorium expires on june 30th
the cdc is in the process of trying to
determine what is the appropriate way
forward
and i would hope that you would ask them
that question and just one more if i can
um
the experts tell us that the december
challenge of covert relief is just now
starting to come
online people that we've talked to are
still seeing some big glitches you know
when they try to apply are you confident
that states and localities now have
the systems in place to get this as well
as the next round of funding
i'm very confident i've talked with
secretary ellen
the treasury department is is up to the
task i mean certainly it is a different
treasury department so i'm very
confident that if they say that they can
get it out in a certain period of time
they will
our job at hud is just to give the kind
of guidance
and assistance once those funds are
received
thank you secretary excuse me um you
mentioned earlier that um
that housing prices are are increasing
also the supply of new inventory on the
market
is decreasing at the same time what can
the administration do to
get more homes on the market or bring
prices down how concerned are you about
about that dynamic
there are a couple of things that we
know can happen out of this rescue
package one is if you look at places
like a los
angeles where they have actually
purchased hotels and
motels etc to give people an immediate
place to go there's re there are
resources
in the plan to do that the other thing
that we find is that
part of the problem with the market is
that credit is not
available and accessible to people who
actually do qualify
so since fha is certainly a part of what
what what we do
we're going to ensure that we can talk
about down payment census we're going to
talk about
maybe some restructuring we are going to
make sure that people who qualify have
access to credit
we all know that there have been
problems uh across this country for many
many years
that is why i'm so pleased that
president biden talks about equity
he talks about equality closing the the
racial wealth gap
which is bigger today than it was 50
years ago
so we we know that we have the tools
i think it was just a matter of making
sure that we have the will to use them
we have the we now have the will
madam secretary thank you again um back
to the homelessness report that you guys
put out this morning the way that test
is done as you know is
you test over a few days in january of
the previous year
so that was pre-pandemic 2020. 580 000
people on the streets
pre i mean homeless pre-pandemic correct
2.2
increase from the year before do you
have any sense of how much
more homelessness may have increased
once that pandemic began
say april may end of the summer i can't
give you numbers we know that it hasn't
increased we just don't know those
numbers so really not until
next january when we able to get some
sense of how it might look like correct
nancy and alex and then we'll have to
let the secretary go back to work go
ahead
thanks so much for being here appreciate
it my pleasure two questions
one does the biden administration have
any plans to restore or tweak that
obama era fair housing regulation which
the trump administration weakened in the
summer of 2020.
we are looking at it certainly we know
that fair housing
is in fact the law of the land and we
want to use every tool we have
i think that the prior administration
did roll back
some fair housing uh tools that we have
so we're looking at how we can
go back and make those better and get
them re-implemented it costs
and then just second question what are
your thoughts on whether or not there's
a housing
bubble right now in the u.s well
i i i would say that that's a kind of a
tricky question
um there are those who would say yes i
would say at this point that until i can
get the kind of data that i need from
the gses and from fha that's not a
that's not something that i could really
give you an accurate answer on
but i know that there is a problem with
the market today
make it a good one alex no pressure well
i got i got two because i'm gonna be
just a little bit greedy
one from our housing reporter which is
are there some parts of the
covid response whether or not an arp or
generally
that are currently temporary that you
would like to see permanent when the
crisis
eases oh i'd like to see most of it
permanent no question about it
i think that when we talk about housing
needs
we can't at this point come up with
enough money
to cate to take care of all the homeless
people in this country
we cannot through this package alone
repair and restore 50 year old housing
authorities across this country which
are crumbling
every day we cannot abate lead
in every single building we need to with
these resources
we need at least another 70 to 100
billion dollars to do those things
so yes i'd like to see a stream of
resources available
to do this not just in this package but
ongoing
and the second question is you may have
seen that former congressman richmond
weighed in on
the primary to succeed him and his
congressional
seat congressman richmond yeah
i've never heard of him um i was
wondering if you want to take the
opportunity to weigh in on your race and
you know who you think can should
succeed you and
what you're looking for no
all right how about the senate race
there democrats will
run oh absolutely
well i have two friends that are
thinking about it tim ryan of course is
thinking about it i understand manueli
is thinking about it
i mean i think we're going to put a good
person in that race no matter who we
choose but they're both friends
i think we have a good shot at it i know
people have written off ohio
i haven't written off ohio i believe we
can win the senate race
thank you secretary looking forward to
having you back thank you
thank you thank you
okay
what'd you say
we can wait till month three wait till
month three
we'll be rolling it out with people's
second visits uh
as we announced yesterday i just wanted
to give you a little bit more
information on the schedule for next
week
you may have seen we confirmed that the
president will be traveling to columbus
ohio on tuesday
the anniversary of the affordable care
act being signed into law
the trip will be a part of our help is
here tour and we'll highlight how the
american rescue plan
will lower health care costs for many
american families and
this is a component of the package that
we've talked about but we're still
working to
ensure the american people understand
how they can benefit from this
particular piece
the affordable care act has been an
important lifeline for ohio families
for 11 years the law cut the state's
uninsured rate by
half dropping from 12 percent to 6
percent it has also provided critical
consumer protections for millions more
by preventing insurance companies
from discriminating based on
pre-existing conditions
and the american rescue plan makes
coverage under the aca even more
affordable for ohio families
over 90 000 currently uninsured ohioans
can get a better deal
on health insurance because of the law
and premiums for people who have
coverage under the aca
and the former ohio governor was one of
the first if not the first republican
governor
in the country to expand medicaid access
during that period of time and that is
something certainly something we
continue to note around here um another
update on the schedule
is uh uh in the week uh well a couple of
updates i should say
part on the schedule and part on steps
we're taking as it relates to the
horrific events in atlanta earlier this
week
in the rake of the horrific shootings in
atlanta on tuesday the president ordered
the u.s flag to be flown at half-staff
as a mark of respect for the victims of
these senseless acts of violence
the president and the vice president
will also meet with representatives
from the georgia asian american and
pacific islander community when they
travel to georgia on friday
they will meet with the state
legislators and community advocates to
hear about the impact of the incident
on the community and to get their
perspective on the rise in anti-asian
hate incidents the president will also
also offer his support for the
aapi community in georgia and across the
country and talk about his commitment to
combating xenophobia
intolerance and hate as many of you may
know and i think we
i've been asked about this and here
previously but senator maisie hirono and
congresswoman grace mang
have introduced legislation that calls
for expanded doj review of covid 19
related hate crimes
for guidance from doj to law enforcement
for best practices in reporting hate
crimes
and ensures that hate crimes information
and reporting is more accessible
to asian american communities the
president applauds this their leadership
on this issue including
along with chair judy choose and he
strongly supports these crucial aims of
this legislation
he issued a presidential memorandum his
first week in office directing the
attorney general to support state and
local agencies
and aapi communities to prevent hate
crimes and expand
data collection and public reporting
that is ongoing the outreach and
engagement from doj is already underway
there's also a role for hhs to play
which we expect can
pick up more once secretary becerra
future secretary basara is
is uh to is sworn in uh and as i noted
yesterday uh
also from here he's asked cedric
richmond uh who of course we've all
heard of and
former congressman and susan rice to
lead an effort to engage with the
community as well
last piece today the house will also be
voting
on the american dream and promise act
and the farm workforce modernization act
president biden and this administration
support passage of both pieces of
legislation
these bills would provide a path to
citizenship for dreamers
individuals with temporary protected
status and farm workers
both pieces of legislation passed the
house last congress with bipartisan
support
and have broad support from the american
public these bills
and his view and our view are critical
milestones toward much needed relief for
the millions of individuals
who call the united states home and an
acknowledgment that a path to
citizenship for these essential workers
is critically important
to our economy and our nation's food and
agricultural sectors
we also urge congress to reform other
aspects of our immigration system
by passing president biden's bill the
u.s citizenship act a
package a bill that he proposed on his
first day in office
which would establish a new system to
responsibly manage
and secure a border bring long overdue
visa reforms to keep families together
and grow our economy
and address the root causes of migration
from central america
with that zeke kick us off thank you jen
um
just following up on a scoop from jeff
over here
a scooplet i don't know that reuters
calls it scooplets
but you can confirm that the us plans to
load uh four million astrazeneca
vaccines
to mexico and canada what's the timeline
for when that investment has actually
taken place
and why only four million of the
stockpile that is several times that
when
her vaccine is in alternative absolutely
so as i've noted here before but worth
noting again
uh our first priority remains
vaccinating the us population
uh the reality is that but the reality
is the border knows no
uh the the uh pandemic knows no borders
and ensuring our neighbors can contain
the virus is a mission critical
step is mission critical to ending the
pandemic we have three vaccines approved
as you well know
and of course there's a rigorous review
process by
the fda there are other vaccines of
course including astrazeneca that are
going through the approval
process now and we have been taking
action here
to get ready to get those vaccines to
the american people if they are approved
as we await fda approval here in the u.s
many countries as you know have already
requested
have requested the have already approved
astrazeneca and also have requested
our doses from the united states
that includes canada and mexico but is
certainly not limited to canada and
mexico
uh and balancing the need to let the
approval process play out of the
astrazeneca vaccine
uh as it's taking place in the us with
the importance of helping stop the
spread
of the of in other countries we are
assessing how we can loan doses it's not
it's it's we are we're that is our aim
it's not fully finalized yet but that is
our aim and what we're working toward
uh to canada and mexico this is a
complex process and our team is working
with the companies
to move it forward and i want to on your
question about the number of doses there
have been
a range of reports about the number of
doses i can confirm that
we have 7 million releasable doses
available
of astrazeneca and as noted in jeff's
scooplet which i'm just going to keep
calling it
uh 2.5 million of those
we are working to finalize plans to
lend those to mexico and 1.5 million to
canada the nature
of that transaction would it just be for
future astrogenetic production
meaning what's what's in the loan yeah
uh it could be for future astrazeneca
doses or other doses yes and
on a different topic i was wondering if
you see you saw the comments from
russian president vladimir putin this
morning uh
uh responding to the president's uh
comments in the interview on tuesday
night
the president worried all that he may
have inadvertently started a little
more words and that uh
training shots backwards and get in the
way of uh having
finding some common ground on various
shared priorities
well president put president biden and
president putin
certainly have different perspectives on
their respective countries
and how to approach engagement in the
world
but where they agree is that we should
continue to work for way look for ways
to work together as was noted and
part of president putin's comments and
there are areas of mutual interest
new start which we just extended for
five years is an example of that
obviously russia is also a member of the
p5 plus one as we look ahead to
what's possible there as it relates to
uh you know preventing iran from
acquiring a nuclear weapon
so uh we are confident that we can
continue to look for ways where there's
a
mutual interest mutual and national
interest but uh the president is not
going to hold back
clearly uh when he has uh concerns uh
when he has
um uh whether it is with words or
actions
uh go ahead i'll go to you you have a
scooplet you can go
after a few other people go ahead
you say that you want to work together
with restaurant areas of mutual
agreement but
russia has now decided to recall its
ambassador i mean is there a concern
that the president agreeing that
russian president putin is a killer
could escalate tension even further
well our ambassador sullivan remains in
moscow
we remain uh engaged and he remains
engaged as is our team on the
ground with the russian people we
continue to believe that diplomacy
is the first step and should always be
the first step and should be our
objective
uh as we pursue all relationships even
with our adversaries uh so
um you know we are hopeful that that
will continue to be the case i just want
to get your reaction to actually
some of putin's exact words here because
he responded with a bit of a euphemism
that translates roughly
to it takes one to no one pointing to
slavery in america treatment of native
americans the atomic bombing of japan
does the person have any response to
that kind of language well the president
believes that one of the greatest
attributes of the united states is our
honest self-reflection
and our constant striving for progress
and there's always more work to do
as he's stated himself uh so
i can't i've been doing this long enough
not to try to get in the mind of
president putin
uh but um i can assure you that uh
president biden uh
still believes there's more work we can
do here in our own country
go ahead just to follow up quickly does
you're talking about self-reflection
does president biden
regret calling vladimir putin a killer
no the president gave a direct answer to
a direct question so then how is that
how
you don't want to escalate tensions how
is that constructive to the relationship
when you talk about
diplomacy being primary between the us
and russia how is calling vladimir putin
a killer
constructed to that relationship well
president biden has known president
putin for a long time they've both been
on the global stage for a long time
worked through many iterations of a
relationship between the united states
and russia uh and he believes we can
continue to do that
does the president believe that the
leaders of
muhammad bin salman the one of the the
crown prince of
saudi arabia does he view him as a
killer i don't think i need to add more
killer names from the podium just today
oh i won't ask about other countries
that as well okay
but let me let me ask you about
immigration yeah if i can quickly the
president has made it very clear in his
in his recent interview
that the border is not open effectively
this is closed except for these
unaccompanied minors right now under
humanitarian ground being welcomed
into the u.s but as we speak crews from
multiple outlets including those from
nbc news are at the border they're
seeing
many migrant families being accepted
young families being accepted into the
country
right now so can you square those two
when the message was that
families and individuals were being sent
home but unaccompanied minors were being
kept
why young families are in fact being
kept here in the u.s
and detained well we've talked about
this a little bit in here before but
and we are still applying section 42 uh
which
uh and with the exception as of course
unaccompanied minors
uh we are there are limited scenarios
limited circumstances where we are very
limited i should say
where uh families are coming across
going through proper protocols at the
border being tested
and and then having their cases
adjudicated part of this is that
part of the reasoning is that of course
we've closed matamoros
and some there there has been some
less participation in keeping some of
these families in mexico than in the
past
in many of these policies we have
supported but the vast majority of
people
vast vast majority who come to the
border are turned away the border is not
open
these are very limited scenarios i'm
sorry i just swallowed some mask here
it's okay
we've all been there how limited is very
limited how many are being allowed in as
it relates to families
and specifically if the message that the
president was sending this week is that
the border is not open
what is the message to those families
given
some are being allowed in right now the
message continues to be i'd be happy to
provide you the numbers i think cbp has
the most up-to-date numbers so i'd point
you to them and they provide those
regularly we'd certainly support that
i don't have them in front of me right
now i would say the message continues to
be
now is not the time to come the vast
majority of families
of individuals are sent back are are not
welcomed across the border
and that's a message we will continue to
convey clearly
you talked about how the president saw
those photos in one of the recent
briefings as it relates to these
shelters
detention centers decompression centers
i'm not sure what specific photos he saw
we asked yesterday we'll ask again today
can you provide those will you provide
those to
the american public to see what it looks
like there right now well first let me
say that the white house and we all in
the administration
support finding a way to grant access to
the media
to the hhs and or facilities or the
shelters where
these children are are staying for a
temporary period of time before they are
placed with family members or with
sponsored homes
the office of refugee right resettlement
is has not been hosting as you've noted
media tours of unaccompanied children
facilities
currently due to the covet 19 epidemic
pandemic but we remain committed to
transparency
and we're considering potential options
and we hope to have an update on that
soon
so even if we didn't get a tour can you
provide us the photos that the president
was provided
they there was a private briefing an
internal briefing from several weeks ago
we typically don't provide those
materials publicly but we do
want you to be able to uh or a pool of
media
to be able to have your own visuals and
get your own footage of these facilities
go ahead two things um back to russia
for a second yeah there was the solar
winds hack there was the
reported bounties on the heads of u.s
yes the president
said in this interview something on that
is coming what is the hold up
when is when is the response from the
united states coming because he
inferred in the interviews you know stay
tuned right well we also have already
uh put forward sanctions on in in
response to the poisoning of alexi
novelani
there's already been a release of a
report about uh their engagement in the
2020 election
and we will have responses to each of
these uh malign actions
that we have expressed concern about and
the president has offered a review of
weeks not months remains still the
policy uh there's of course internal
policy
decision making about uh to to assess
and take a look at the review but also
to make decisions about policy
engagements
some of the responses may be seen some
may be unseen
and of course the president reserves the
right to respond at a manner in time of
his choosing
as any president would but he did make
clear that their that the
russian government will pay a price on
these vaccines going to mexico
this comes of course as the united
states is talking to mexico about this
border situation
were there any strings attached
regarding the situation on the border
with this decision to give after
xenophodosis to mexico
there are several diplomatic
conversations parallel conversations
many layers of conversations with
any every country mexico canada europe
asia around the world and certainly uh
being part of
contributing to preventing the spread of
a global pandemic is part of one of our
diplomatic objectives
another one of our diplomatic objectives
is working to address the challenges
uh at the border uh so it shouldn't be a
surprise that those conversations are
both ongoing and happening i'm hearing
you
the vaccine was given where their
expectations set with the mexicans
that they helped deal with the situation
on the border the
there have been there have there have
been expectations set outside of
unrelated to any vaccine doses or
requests for them
that they would be partners in dealing
with the crisis on the border
and there have been requests unrelated
that uh they for doses of these vaccines
um every relationship has multiple
layers of conversations that are
happening at the same time
rule out or the united states isn't
ruling out using our vaccine stockpile
in terms of i'm actually trying i'm
actually trying to convey that
with every country there's there's
rarely just one issue you're discussing
with any country at one time
right certainly that's not the case with
mexico it's not the case with any
country around the world
um and so uh i wouldn't read into it
more than our
ability to provide to lend vaccine doses
of a vaccine that we have some available
supply on to a neighboring country where
there is a lot of traffic that goes back
and forth between the countries
two other quick ones one relating to the
atlanta shooting you've been asked this
before but
in february of last year then candidate
biden said that on his first day of
office he'd send a bill to congress
repealing the liability protection for
gun manufacturers
and closing the background check blue
coin now you've been asked about this
there's an attorney general in place now
when if any when might we hear more
about the administration's plans
regarding gun violence
it remains a commitment a personal
commitment of the president
to do more on gun safety to put more
measures in place
to use the power of the presidency to
work with congress
and certainly there is an important role
as you noted for the attorney general
and the justice department to play
on in this regard i unfortunately don't
have any updates for you today
but it is an issue he remains committed
to one quick local issue the house
oversight committee on monday is holding
a hearing on bc statement
president is a supporter of this yes
does he think it could
if it passes the house does it have a
chance in the senate given the
filibuster situation right now
and what would he or the white house say
to the critics who
suggests that this is designed to be a
democratic party power grab just to get
a few more seats
in the house in the senate i think he
would say that um
the half a million people who live in dc
am i getting that number right
a little more than it's grown since i
left and went to the suburbs uh
would would argue with that point and so
would he i mean he believes they deserve
representation that's why he uh supports
d.c statehood go ahead
has the administration made any effort
this is just a putin relationship
has the administration made any effort
to find out what was said during the
previous president's two-hour
long one-on-one meeting with putin in
helsinki
that's a great question obviously
there's intelligence reports that may
reflect that but i'm not aware of any
specific deep dive into that i'm happy
to check if there's more on it
and just i'm sorry one more question um
the chinese government has indicated
that it wanted
it wants to meet with president biden
virtually in april before that climate
summit
i'm wondering if the biden
administration is open to that
and if there have been any talks about
studying that meeting i know we'll have
more on the climate summit which is just
over a month away now so it's coming
closer and there are of course a range
of international
global participants uh that we
anticipate being a part of it but
we're not at the stage where we're
discussing bilateral meetings at this
point in time
go ahead david oh sorry jeff i really
i'll come back to you next
i'm not trying to give you a hard time
go ahead david maybe mr snooply should
go first
yeah maybe
sorry to uh go back to the russia
question here but
um the president now by my account has
said that russia would pay a price for
solar winds
he has said that they would pay a price
for navalny and as you pointed out
they've already been some sanctions
there yeah
yesterday he seemed to suggest that
they would pay a price in addition for
the meddling in the 2020
uh election and yet at the same time
your own colleagues seem to have
sanctions fatigue out here
in the government or your your
colleagues have been in the
in the state department the west wing i
mean you announced sanctions on
russia back when you were state
department spokesperson
is there any evidence that the method
that we're using so far
of sanctions is actually affecting
putin's behavior
i don't think we would rely david on
sanctions alone uh we do think
they have been effective uh modes i mean
history you've written many stories
about it about the role sanctions have
played in moving
global diplomacy forward and we
certainly are a believer in that
but uh as you also know there are a
range of tools at any price at the
disposal of any president
seen and unseen and i'm just not going
to get ahead of the process of what
considerations are underway
okay on china uh obviously the
meeting is yet to happen today
but at the end of this whole process
uh once mr sullivan and mr blinken come
back
what does the president think is the
next right step
is it further meetings at this level
is it more direct conversation like the
one he had for several hours
last month with president xi
is it a response to
the chinese related hack that he's also
trying to deal with i expect he'll make
a determination about that
when they return and he has a chance to
talk to secretary blinken
and national security adviser sullivan
in part because he doesn't see this nor
do they
as a preset series of meetings like
the traditional um dialogues that we've
seen
uh throughout other administrations
including ones that he has previously
served in
uh you know this meeting we certainly
anticipate
we'll have difficult components of the
conversation we expect it to be
frank uh they plan to cover areas where
we have concerns
including human rights uh hong kong uh
obviously we've uh we've put forward
some sanctions uh related to the
anti-democratic actions in hong kong
over the last couple of days
technology whether it relates to thraft
the theft of
ip or data protections
military tensions in the region so it
will cover as will be no surprise to
anyone here who
follows china closely a range of topics
and i think the president's eager to
hear from them on
how the conversation goes and work with
them to determine what the next straight
step is
i will say that in his mind and in the
minds of national security advisor
sullivan and
and secretary of state um blinken a big
part of the strategy
is uh approaching our relationship with
china from
a place of strength and strengthening
our
uh own economy at home investing in the
middle class
looking at it through the prism of uh
competition not conflict and
that means there's also more work we
have to do here from your answer things
like the economic and strategic dialogue
which took place in the obama
administration that
continued some in the in the trump
administration
that's over for now i i would simply say
that this meeting is not a part of a
series of
of meetings at this point in time go
ahead
oh sorry jeff you're kind of getting
hazed for your scooplet
right i know you can okay he'll just sit
on his scooplet he doesn't care go ahead
karen
a couple questions on schools um last
month the cdc released school guidance
urging six feet of distance between
students and staff
and now the cdc director says she's
revisiting this we're reporting that
this could come as early as tomorrow
then that will go from six feet to three
feet
what does the white house say to
teachers who are concerned that the
science hasn't changed in five weeks and
that this is
political this change i would say that
uh the cdc
is full of health and medical experts
including dr wolenski who would be the
last person to characterize herself as
political
she is a medical health expert and she
has
looked at this through the prism of how
we can
take steps to make it safe to reopen
schools
and is constantly evaluating how to ease
some of the restrictions and
they're of course more that often you've
all have asked about in here which are
good questions
what about travel what about masks uh
you know they take an approach that is
purely through the science so we'll let
her speak more about it when they're
ready to release those formal guidelines
the white house directs states to do
something with that guidance when it's
released similar to what we saw when the
president
made the direction on vaccine
eligibility
you mean like will we direct schools to
now do this the cdc has said this
six to three feet you now have to follow
this to push for reopening
well social distancing is one of the
mitigation measures right in the cdc
guidance and i don't know i have not
seen the cdc guidance
so i don't know how it will be
characterized in there but i would
certainly say we'd have secretary
cardona
who was just here yesterday work with
schools and school districts to
implement
and social distancing is one of the
steps masking testing
vaccinations and see how it can help
reopen schools more quickly
i mean kind of overnight go from six to
three feet in the schools that are open
right now and possibly increase the
number of students that
can be in the classroom before the end
of the year i don't have a timeline for
it i don't anticipate we'd ask any
school to do something immediately
overnight
um but it will just be additional
guidance which a lot of schools are
looking for
from health and medical experts on on
how to safely reopen schools and ensure
that
the the parents in the community the
teachers in the community the students
feel safe going to school and this just
as they're considering options this is
one of the options
uh that will that one of the mitigation
steps of school can take
uh go ahead um two quick questions
uh to continue with the scooplet theme
okay um
there was a report just about an hour
ago that
the president intends to nominate bill
nelson as nasa chief
can you confirm that i've seen those
reports i don't have any personal
announcements to make today
seems like a cool job though then i'm
not currently on the path too but
it's fine you're not auditioning right
now i am certainly not i don't have any
personal announcements to make certainly
seen the reports as we have any updates
we'll provide them
and second question you know the
president said yesterday that he intends
to
try to raise taxes on anyone that was
making over 400 000
a year uh does he think that that's uh
does he intend to wait until the economy
is out of
uh the pandemic recession or
does he feel confident that
that by making it only on higher earners
that it will not affect the broader
economy
well the president is certainly focused
on ensuring the economy is continuing to
recover and that people are
going back to work and able to put food
on the table to
feed their families when we're talking
about people families making over four
hundred thousand dollars a year
that's about two percent of households
in this country
and this is a commitment that he talked
about on the campaign trail
and his interest is in ensuring that
people
pay their fair share whether it's
corporations or the highest income
earners in our country
and uh he believes that um you know hard
work should be
rewarded and that this is one of the
areas where there could where there is
an opportunity to
rebalance uh how our policies are
currently
but i you know he would do this in
coordination with of course
members of congress members of his
economic team and we obviously don't
have a proposed plan at this point but
it is a it is a
um a policy that he talked about on the
campaign trail and he reiterated as you
noted earlier this week
did you have a second question too or
not those are the two
questions okay okay got it okay okay go
ahead jeff
all right the man of the hour that
the u.s has seven million doses
releasable doses and the company itself
has said
uh expects to have up to 30 million in
april
given that will the u.s consider lending
sharing more of these doses with the
other countries that are asking
now that you've confirmed that you're
doing the same for mexico and canada
we don't have anything to preview but we
all have a number of requests
from a range of countries around the
world and certainly will continue those
conversations
okay but no good commitment at this
point to share specifically the
astrazeneca
vaccine with others well i will say
broadly speaking we also
anticipate having additional doses of
moderna a pfizer of a range of vaccines
even as we focus on vaccinating ensuring
every american every adult american has
access to the vaccine
it's just a matter of timeline so i just
don't have a an update or a preview on
that but certainly we'll have those
conversations and we are
open to receiving those requests and and
obviously
making considerations all right and just
on one other issue your
new us trade representative will be
ceremonially sworn in
later today um 97 to 0.
i think
how soon will she start leading
uh trade talks with the uk i don't have
anything to preview
obviously that's driven by the policies
and the agenda of
the president and the overall economic
team i'm sure we'll be integrating her
into all of the policy discussions as as
soon as she's sworn in
let me just go to the get to the folks
in the back go ahead thank you ma'am a
couple quick questions
when you were talking a moment ago about
diplomatic negotiations between the
united states and mexico
um you said crisis on the border is
was that a uh challenge is on the border
okay
but so that's not that doesn't reflect
any change in
the administration's view of things nope
okay
well uh another quick question then on
monday the president said it's important
to get the vaccine
and then quote even after that until
everyone is
vaccinated to wear this mask unquote uh
was he speaking generally or does he
believe that
we should all be wearing masks until
everyone is in fact vaccinated
well i think what he's reflecting is the
guidance from our health experts that
even if you're vaccinated i am
vaccinated i still wear a mask
because there hasn't been conclusive
studies yet
on the transferability of the the
uh uh pandemic or covid uh
for from those who have been vaccinated
he's and he it continues to be the
advice of health and medical experts to
continue to wear masks
every american is that the standard
until everyone american has been
vaccinated or was he speaking generally
i think he's speaking generally about
the need to still observe
measures like social distancing and
wearing of masks
so that even when you're vaccinated
you're keeping your neighbors your
friends
your family members safe and then back
in january
you noted that the administration was
reviewing how unmarried couples were
handled under travel restrictions have
there been any developments on those
restrictions
um i know that there's a lot on the
administration's plate yeah but in how
um unmarried uh bi-national couples
are are treated i don't have any update
for you the review is ongoing
one more question sure thank you you're
very generous um
the equality act as it's currently
written would eliminate the religious
freedom restoration act
uh as a defense for religious
organizations against discrimination
claims given that president biden vote
in favor
of rifra uh does he support it being
abolished now
i would have to check on the specific
components of the package i'm happy to
i'm happy to do that for you after the
briefing go ahead in the back
thank you very much um two easter
questions
and one uh asian american question okay
from u.s china talks can we expect the
joint statement after talks
a joint statement uh between them i i
don't have anything to preview i know
that
um uh national security adviser sullivan
and
secretary blinken will be speaking
briefly after the
talks conclude but i don't have anything
to preview for you in terms of a joint
statement
okay another question is according to
japanese media
uh japanese prime minister asuba will
meet president biden on april
9. can you complain that i know there
have been reports
about a future meeting and the
president's certainly looking forward to
meeting with the prime minister of japan
i don't believe a final confirmation has
been made
here of what that meeting will look like
and what the format would be okay
one asian american question okay from
the unfortunate
atlanta shooting we already see the half
staff
outside um yesterday you blamed the
prior administration about this which
some people agree but as what
uh actuals reports quote
the united states rivalry with china had
already created an east about
chinese americans and asian americans
unquote
and actually states we are going to see
a huge
jump in hate crimes against asian
americans
this year so it seems to be that
president biden is in this catch 22.
um on the one hand he is trying to
alleviate
uh the hate crimes against asians and
asian americans
on the other hand he's kind of escalates
the tension
how can he really alleviate
this situation i would just refute the
notion of that question
i would say that yesterday i was asked
which was a good question
if we thought that the former
president's rhetoric
had contributed to uh the um
actions or the um the discrimination
against asian americans and i said we do
because
rhetoric uh certainly from the the um
the massive megaphone you have from the
white house is something that is heard
across the country
and it's important to then be thoughtful
about the words you use and how you
convey
uh opposition to discrimination of any
kind uh
that was the answer the question i was
answering uh
the president is and the vice president
are meeting with leaders of the asian
american community tomorrow
uh they the president raised the rhetor
the his concerns about
rhetoric about attacks about threats
against the asian american community in
the country
during his prime time address he signs
an executive order
he's asked his members of the
administration to
listen hear think about policy solutions
i would say he's his effort is to be
part of the solution not part of the
problem
uh so i would uh just dispute your uh
your question
go ahead in the back thanks jeff a few
questions for you
the president mentioned in his abc
interview uh
his thoughts on potential changes to the
filibuster
does he support getting rid of the 60
vote threshold on the legislative
filibuster
i think what he said is that he'd be
open to hearing ideas about going back
to the talking filibuster which
mr smith goes to washington is the best
reference that
anyone can make on that front obviously
that hasn't been uh
the law in the senate for since before i
was born uh so many years
but he that is a that is a proposal that
had been put forward by
senator manchin and his whole point is
that and as
he said in his uh comments you know our
democracy looks at moments like it's
broken
and it shouldn't be so easy to block
legislation
at the same time his preference and his
priority
is working with democrats and
republicans to find a pathway forward on
a range of issues where there has been a
history of bipartisan support whether
it's
infrastructure immigration addressing
making our economy and our workers more
competitive against
uh against the competition with china
there are a lot of ways we can work
together that's his preference and so he
was just expressing an openness to
hearing from members of the senate on
what their ideas are
ultimately though as president he
doesn't get it he doesn't vote here it's
not a law he signs into law it's a
senate rule
so uh you'll have to talk to them about
uh what their ideas are and what they
have the votes for
to move forward he would defer to
senators on whether they would support
it's not about deferring he's not in the
senate he doesn't decide
what the senate roles are they do
influence if he were to voice an opinion
he's going to have the the senators
decide uh what
uh what rules they want to abide by
moving forward
a couple other quick ones um i wonder
there are a few key agencies that have
yet to have
a senate nominator to confirm the
leaders that are um certainly the news
now
uh cbp ice um the fda
during the pandemic i wonder does the
administration have any plans or a
timetable for when it might
put forward nominees to lead those
agencies all important agencies
i don't have any update on the personnel
process but we're working our way
through and ensuring we have the right
people
we can nominate for each of those
important roles and then lastly um i
wonder
uh this week there's a group of college
basketball players ahead of the ncaa
tournament
who started a protest on social media
with the hashtag not
ncaa property they're looking for more
financial freedom and
personal protections from the ncaa i
wonder um
one of the things they're asking for is
a meeting with federal officials and
potentially the biden administration to
talk about legislation on this
so does the president support uh
college athletes being able to profit
off their name and likeness and
would the administration be willing to
meet with these players if they ask for
a meeting
i'm happy to see if there's any plans
for a meeting and if we've received the
request
go in the back thank you jen um
questions from the u.s china meeting
china has a poor record of keeping
promises so how would you characterize
um the level of trust that the current
administration has
with regard to china and also for the
for the uh china for the bilateral
meeting between president biden
and president xi um what are the
conditions
that has to be happened what are the
conditions for the meeting to happen
thank you i don't think i'm here to set
conditions today there we haven't even
announced the specific details about
the um climate summit that's happening
in april which i think
was what the bilateral question was
around and
we certainly haven't made a final
decision about any bilateral meetings
around that meeting
as we do i'm sure we can discuss it
further uh and then as it relates uh
to the meeting uh today i i think one
uh that starts today i should say um it
was important to
our administration that the first
meeting uh with
chinese officials be held on american
soil and occur
after we have met and consulted closely
with partners and allies in both asia
and europe
this is an opportunity to address a wide
variety of issues including ones where
we have deep disagreements
and so our focus is on having a frank
discussion
raising issues where we have concerns
and of course looking for ways and
places where we can work together
uh go ahead thanks uh while you've been
briefing president putin has just
extended an invitation to president
biden to continue their conversation
but this time he wants to do it live
he's asking for a live streamed
conversation an open direct dialogue
putin says he's available tomorrow or
monday
is this something that you would
consider uh i'll have to
get back to you if that is something we
are entertaining i would say that the
president
already had a conversation already with
president putin even if
as there are more world leaders that he
has not yet engaged with and we engage
with
russian leaders members of the
government at all levels
uh but i don't have anything to report
to you in terms of a future meeting the
president will of course be in georgia
tomorrow and quite busy go ahead one
very quick final question on the wall
on day one in office i think it was the
president signed a proclamation that was
effectively putting a pause or halting
wall construction
um at the time i think he directed
federal agencies to formulate a plan
within
60 days depending who's counting we're
on 58 59 or
we have two more days do we have okay
someone said two tonight i thought it
was one but we'll go with two more days
to redirect order fund border wall funds
and quote resume
modify or terminate segments of the
structure that remain
under construction have those federal
agencies provided you
with their conclusions have you come to
a conclusion
what is the status of that with that
remaining one or two days left
i will check and see if there's an
update we
are of course there is funding that was
appropriated previously that is still
moving forward
money that has not been appropriated as
you noted we've kind of pulled back
on uh but i will check and see we have
two more days which is a lifetime in
this place
uh and see if we have an update for you
on this step thank you
thank you everyone
it's okay oh it's your first day i'm
sorry
welcome so a lot of my colleagues uh in
this room and outside the tournament
have been asking for a while now about
the possibility of visiting
these facilities where uncompany and
children are being held after
arriving and applying for asylum at the
border and part of the pushback that
we've received from you and from dhs and
hhs
uh is that their privacy concerns um
about reporters potentially
you know and covet and privacy concerns
of coco but specifically to privacy
reporters have been allowed inside these
facilities for years through multiple
administrations by multiple agencies
including by the last administration
during
the family separation crisis where i
think the risk of like further emotional
damage these kids is pretty acute
so has there been to your knowledge any
instant
incident in which a kid's privacy was
violated by reporters who were there to
cover the facilities which they're being
detained
during the last administration during
like the long history of reporters
i would say as i noted in response to a
question or two questions that were
asked earlier that were very similar
our big concern has been the pandemic
and covid and safety of course there are
privacy concerns that
anyone takes into account or i would say
any administration should take into
account
as it relates to members of the media
visiting a facility where there are
children as i'm as i'm sure you would
certainly
agree on i can't speak to what the
approach was of the prior administration
who was ripping children from the arms
of their parents so
i can't speak to what their policies
were but we are working and we're very
committed here from the white house and
from the
government and finding a way soon very
soon to ensure that there is access by
the media
not by not by us providing you with what
we see but by the media
to these shelter facilities uh we
believe it's important and vital and
we're committed to it and we're just
working through the pandemic is about
the safety of staff the safety of kids
as well and that's uh that's what we're
working through at this point in time so
hopefully i'll have an update soon
thanks everyone okay social distancing
speaking out
yeah um the president said uh in the
interview when he was discussing
uh going back to you know talking
filibuster uh
that the filibusters wanted mine because
we're almost getting to a point where
democracy is having a hard time
functioning but
my colleague points out that that
dynamic has been true specifically in
the senate for
a very long time years even um so was
there anything specific to the current
dynamic in the senate
uh that made president biden sort of
decide that
you know now is a moment to change the
filibuster sure well as i answered in
response to the question just a few
minutes ago
uh there are a number of ideas that
members of the senate have put forward
uh
they're they range some are against
changing the filibuster in the
democratic party some are for it some
are for
going back to a talking filibuster back
to the days of
mr smith goes to washington he's he's
watching it closely he was in the senate
for 36 years he's happy to hear their
ideas
his preference remains working with
democrats and republicans to get
business done for the american people so
it's a conversation as you well know
that's happening on capitol hill
right now and he's certainly watching it
as most other people are as well
thank you everyone